hey youtubers is charlie so big news
legends of tomorrow just started
shooting their first episode it's going
to be a two-part pilot which kind of
makes sense because they're billing it
is this big blockbuster compared to
arrow in the flash I've done a bunch of
videos explaining who some of the
villains are but just to be clear the
biggest villains like the big villains
of the season from air on the flash will
cross over with legends of tomorrow just
like the heroes will what's going to
happen is is because air on the flash
start in a couple weeks and then you
know go to the mid-season finale than
they gon break and then they come back
legends of tomorrow isn't starting till
air on the flash come back in January so
the first half of the season on arrow on
the flash will set up all the big
legends of tomorrow characters will meet
Hawkgirl will probably meet Hawkman will
meet Vandal Savage rip hunter everybody
in addition don't be surprised if the
actress that's doing the voice for vixen
crosses over to the live-action series
and gets to be on legends of tomorrow
too she has big enough powers I think a
lot of that will just depend on how
successful they think their vixen
experiment the web series has been now I
said legends of tomorrow just started
shooting their first episode air on the
flash are filming around episode 6 or 7
by now maybe not quite episode 7 episode
8 is actually the first episode that
we're going to beat Vandal Savage in now
that's going to be the arrow flash
crossover last year we called it flare
oh so if you're new to arrow or the
flash when people say flare oh they're
talking about the big midseason
crossover so I'm guessing it Vandal
Savage is going to show up in that
episode that we might also see rip
hunter show up in that episode there's
been a lot of behind-the-scenes legend
stuff like that then doing the first
read-through the script but we haven't
seen a lot of Arthur Darvill most of the
pictures we've seen have been from the
other characters but I guess maybe
Arthur Darvill is just been busy filming
other stuff so if you're confused about
how all the heroes end up coming
together like how they convince captain
cold who's a villain to help them out
that's all going to be dealt with the
first half of the season on air on the
flash resurrecting Sara Lance's probably
one of the biggest things like that's
gonna be the Constantine episode of
arrow season 4 he's going to help them
resurrect her and and presumably she'll
have this new persona of the white
canary that's who she's playing she's
gonna be the white canary if you have
read the comics and you know who the
white canary is you're like wait a
minute this doesn't make sense the white
canary is a completely different
character in the comics they're just
using the name they're not using her
persona from the comic
so for just forget about white canary in
the comic books the real thing I'm
interested to find out is which of the
characters you know be them heroes or
villains already know about Vandal
Savage because if he's immortal he's
been around for forever presumably
somebody would have heard of him last
year the best example that was a bart
dawn he was from the future so of course
he's gonna know about everything that's
already happened but because this year
we don't know where he is the only
person from the future that's going to
have like for knowledge of what ends up
happening is going to be our third our
files characters gonna be rip hunter
just a dress that I know everyone's kind
of confused as to you know what happened
with the reverse flash in the flash
finale was he erased from existence what
about Harrison wells in tom cavanagh
like the actor the most logical
explanation was is is that Barry's
actions in the flash finale retcon what
the reverse flash did to the original
version of Harrison wells so that he
never became the reverse-flash he just
continued being a regular scientist the
flash people have since clarified that
Harrison wells of season two will be
from earth-2 so it sounds like they're
sidestepping a lot of logic issues how's
this person still alive because these
XYZ well he's from earth-2 he's just an
alternate universe version and a lot of
you guys asked about earth two villains
like are they going to be the only
villains we see like will we see any
more metahumans yes there will be
metahumans on arrow in the flash in
season two but now they're starting to
introduce the idea of naturally
occurring metahumans as isn't metahumans
that already had powers before the
particle accelerator explosion so you
have people like vixen you have people
like death bolt from arrow season 3 I
mean he's dead now but you get the idea
so the villains of arrow in the flash
this season will be a combination of
naturally occurring metahumans people
from earth-2 and then just other regular
criminals like we see on arrow most of
the super-powered stuff we're going to
see is going to be on the flash you have
heroes without powers they fight
villains without powers you have heroes
with superpowers they fight villains
with superpowers but just because
episode 8 is the big arrow flash
crossover with Vandal Savage doesn't
mean that they're not going to do minor
crossovers like if you remember the
flash episode 18 the atom and Felicity
went to STAR Labs to get some help with
his suit like that was kind of a minor
crossover so we'll see stuff like that
too it's just that the episode 8 arrow
flash crossover is when like the entire
main cast goes on each other shows
thinking about legends of tomorrow again
I think is going to happen is is they're
going to do err on the flash the first
half of the season they're going to
reduce all these characters they'll do
the episode 8 crossover and then the
events of the mid-season finale and that
crossover will set up what's going on
when we start an episode one of legends
of tomorrow so blows up in
everyone's faces on the flash and arrow
in the mid-season finale and then they
deal with that in the first episode of
legends of tomorrow like oh we need
to form a team and deal with this now
the only characters from flash and arrow
that I know are also going to crossover
with legends of tomorrow are burying
Oliver but I wouldn't be surprised if
some of the other big characters crossed
over in a minor way to the really cool
thing about legends of tomorrow though
is that they said that they would be
visiting big moments in DC comic book
history because I mean they'll be
they'll be time traveling Marc
Guggenheim also said that you know just
because they're heroes doesn't mean
they're not going to derp like they're
gonna derp across time and space Doctor
Who style because some of the moments
that they visit will be from their own
histories they'll try and change things
to make them better and obviously that's
gonna cause a lot of problems have to
solve them like they might go back to
the night of the particle accelerator
explosion and someone might try and stop
that from happening but if you stop that
from happening and you stop the flash
from being created and things go way way
worse or like they might go back to the
night that Oliver and Sarah got stranded
on the island you saw that from
happening you stop Oliver from getting
his hero arc and becoming the arrow and
none of this happens if you guys have
ever seen a time travel movie you know
it's always bad news when you try and
change your own history so so obviously
that's going to be a big theme at
legends of tomorrow I'm actually
interested to see like how close to
Doctor Who they get with things a big
rule of doctor who is that the doctor
does not interact with himself from
different time periods but the funny
thing is is that he breaks that rule all
the time so we might see the characters
trying to talk to themselves from the
past and from the future please give me
spoilers from the future so I can change
things you guys can let me know that
which moments from DC comic book history
do you want to see them go visit like do
you want to see them visit the creation
of the Justice League or the Justice
Society I'd be really interested to see
if they're going to be allowed to do
something like that the show itself is
kind of a Justice Society show but i'm
wondering if Werner brothers told them
that that name was off limits like even
though you have all these characters
from justice society you can't call it
just a society that that might not be
the case but if you guys are looking for
a comic book to read
has something to do with legends of
tomorrow read rip hunter in the time
masters a lot of the logic of the series
is going to be based on the time masters
from the comics just to remind you guys
legends of tomorrow won't premiere till
January they haven't decided exactly how
many episodes are going to be but I'm
assuming it's going to be somewhere
around 13 but I think it just depends on
how much money they want to spend per
episode let me know if there are any
Legends videos that you guys want me to
do for any characters or storylines be
sure to subscribe to get everything most
of my videos are going to be flash arrow
videos because they'll be setting
characters up but I will do separate
videos for legends characters like
Hawkman there been a whole bunch of
trailers in the last couple days so in
case you guys haven't seen it you can
click here for the latest flash trailer
it shows off Jay Garrick for the first
time and you can click here for the
arrow season 4 trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you